bueno en el año 2004 recibiendo llamadas
para acompañar al presidente y parte del
gobierno del principado a un viaje
institucional a china una vez allí uno
de los días tuvimos una recepción con un
miembro del gobierno chino y tuve que
tocar la gaita
bueno todo bien había tocado el día
anterior había tocado ese día por la
mañana sin problema así que voy cojo la
gaita
voy a soplar y cuando voy a tocar
la gaita no suena
imaginaros el momento los chinos sin
entender nada
los asturianos venga empieza tío pieza y
yo sin saber qué hacer por suerte tenía
unos compañeros al lado me dejaron su
gaita y pude tocar
esta situación que a priori parece a
parecería bochornosa y lo fue un poco
[Música]
me ayuda mucho porque me hizo pensar en
qué ha pasado y lo más importante por
qué ha pasado esto
en ese mismo año mientras bernard se
ponía rojo delante del gobierno chino yo
me encontraba iniciando mis estudios de
ingeniería aquí en gijón
en aquel entonces yo no sabía lo que era
la impresión 3d ni qué relación podría
tener con las gaitas el instrumento
favorito de mi abuela y la principal
razón por la que empecé a tocarla fue
años más tarde quizás algunos lo
recordaréis cuando salió las noticias un
chico que se había impreso su propia
pistola impresa en 3-d
esto me hizo interesarme y empezar a
investigar por el tema sin ningún afán
delictivo
y la conclusión a la que pude llegar fue
clara la impresión 3d democratiza a los
procesos productivos qué quiere decir
esto esto quiere decir que con esto una
impresora de unos 200 euros que solo
imprime hasta 10 centímetros de altura
somos capaces de fabricar pues no sólo
adornos un llavero sino que somos
capaces de fabricar un instrumento como
la gaita como os preguntaréis pues bueno
por ejemplo aquí tenemos el puntero de
la gaita que es el encargado de que
produzca el sonido a través de una
lengüeta como otros instrumentos de
viento como podéis ver es una pieza que
mide más de 30 centímetros de altura y
el primer favor otro prototipo que
fabricamos fue con esa impresora por lo
que lo tuvimos que hacer en cuatro
trozos unidos os voy a enseñar un vídeo
de cómo sonaba ese primer prototipo
ahora
[Música]
como habéis podido comprobar la prueba
fue todo un éxito
esto que todos estáis pensando por dios
no vuelvas a tocar más para nosotros fue
un punto de inflexión fue un punto de
inflexión porque cuando planteamos la
idea por primera vez dudamos incluso de
poder fabricar algo que emitiese algún
tipo de sonido después el acceso a
mejores máquinas nos permitió hacer el
puntero en dos piezas
y posteriormente lo pudimos fabricar en
una sola pieza aún recuerdo con cariño
aquel día que cogí la pieza según había
acabado de imprimirse y me fui corriendo
a cudillero para que lo probase berna
tenemos retratado el momento posterior a
esa prueba
nuevamente
efe
bueno aparte de ver que me llevo mucho
pelo el proyecto
ya está
os preguntaréis cómo utilizamos las
nuevas tecnologías para fabricar una
gaita bueno para para ello tenemos que
pensar primeramente de qué está
fabricada la gaita la gaita
tradicionalmente están fabricadas de
madera la madera es un material vivo que
quiero decir con un material vivo quiere
decir que cuando cortamos la madera y la
transformamos en una mesa en una silla
en una gaita la madera sigue viviendo es
decir cuando sigue cambiando cuando
cambia la temperatura cuando cambia la
humedad además la forma en que se hace
tradicionalmente la gaita normalmente la
hace un artesano de forma
mayoritariamente manual esto qué pasa
que no nos permite estandarizar el
producto y os preguntaréis
para qué quiere se estandarizaron la
gaita no
bueno pues imaginaros pensar un poco lo
que me pasó a mí en china si en vez de
uno fuéramos una banda de 20 personas
cómo hacer para afinar todas esas gaitas
que suenen bien una locura no pues en
muchas ocasiones así es
bueno pero el reto que teníamos hugo yo
no era sólo hacer una gaita en 3-d
nuestro reto era mejorar además la gaita
que teníamos
entonces como hacíamos esto nosotros
ayudamos la tecnología aquí veis un
render de un puntero el puntero es la
parte donde ponemos los dedos es una de
las piezas que mejoramos como la
mejoramos pues aquí se colocan los dedos
en los agujeros lo que hicimos fue
juntar los agujeros para que para que
sea mucho más fácil de tocar
además modificamos las geometrías
internas para mejorar tanto la
estabilidad como la claridad del sonido
de la gaita eso sí siempre sin salirnos
de la tradición y sin dejar de ser una
gaita
o de los problemas al que tuvimos que
enfrentarnos fue a la elección de los
materiales cada día estaban saliendo
nuevos materiales al mercado para
impresión 3d que nosotros nosotros
queríamos implementar en el resto de
partes de la gaita por ejemplo el roncón
que es el encargado de hacer la melodía
de acompañamiento está formado por
piezas que son alargadas esbeltas y que
necesitan de cierta resistencia es por
tanto que tuvimos que realizar estudios
y pruebas para determinar cuáles eran
las mejores características para estas
piezas
por ejemplo fabricamos con nuestras
propias manos un horno con una sonda y
con un regulador de temperatura para
hacer tratamientos térmicos y mejorar
estas propiedades
otras de las pruebas que realizamos
fueron ensayos de flexión para
determinar cuánto era la mejoría de
todas estas modificaciones que estábamos
aplicando
otra de las piezas sobre la que tuvimos
que realizar estudios fue sobre la
boquilla porque es la pieza que tú te
introduces en la boca para meter el aire
en el interior de la gaita y claro tiene
que estar fabricada con materiales no
nocivos
tradicional pensarán muchos no la gaita
un instrumento típicamente tradicional
que pinta un ordenador que pintan unos
planos una impresora 3d que queda del
artesano que hace la gaita con mimo si
vale pero nosotros creemos que y al
igual que los nuevos artesanos utilizan
nuevas herramientas para poder hacer la
gaita nosotros nos utilizamos de las
herramientas del siglo 21 para poder
hacer el mismo instrumento pero pudiendo
solventar los problemas que tiene un
artesano de forma tradicional
una forma de plasmar en el siglo 21 esta
mano del artesano que mencionamos es a
través de la creatividad
ayudándonos de estas herramientas pues
podemos plasmar de forma virtual todas
aquellas ideas que podamos tener en la
mente y después traerlas a la realidad
con un nuevo método productivo que sería
tremendamente complicado a través de los
medios tradicionales podríamos estar
hablando largo y tendido de este
proyecto de más de cuatro años de
duración sobre todas las pruebas que
hemos realizado sobre todos los modelos
que hemos tenido que desechar pero nos
gustaría enseñaros hoy aquí una gaita
completamente impresa en 3-d rediseñada
bajo los cánones del siglo 21 y creemos
que puede ser una vía para el desarrollo
de todas aquellas ideas que tenéis en la
mente y que se pueden llevar a cabo
reflexionar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o no
[Música]
i
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]